we're back with Gabrielle Union now we
need to talk about your new impactful
incredibly powerful show truth be told
that's on Apple TV plus it's about truth
how do we face the truth you've been
truthful about things that have happened
in your life that happen in the show how
do we be brave enough to not shy away
from these subjects and face them
because they are happening and they are
real absolutely it's it's just what you
just said it's it's being honest it's
being clear
um and it's Having the courage of
conviction to stand in your truth and as
audience members and as people who have
to receive this information perhaps
don't make people complicit in their own
abuse perhaps when people tell you
what's happening to them believe them
the first time perhaps have more
compassion
and understanding
and then provide people the resources
and the time needed for healing and and
to address those issues so when we talk
about on truth be told season three the
issue of sexual trafficking of black and
brown girls and a disparate treatment
that that happens in terms of awareness
media attention resources law
enforcement response so here's some
Stark statistics last year 71
000 children 17 and under of black girls
went missing last year
71 000. that's shocking that's that's
that's I mean it's criminal obviously
but how many of their names have you
heard
and it's nine out of ten of those
were immediately labeled as runaways
when you're labeled a runaway that means
there's a delayed response there's no
there's no Amber Alert there's a delayed
response by law enforcement and the
investigation is delayed and if you
watch crime shows you know that the
first you know what 48 Hours 72 hours
are critical yeah in recovery
so what can we do about that because the
show is so beautifully elegantly
elevated and it does face all this and
discuss it but you know well we have a
clip here I want to show everybody I'm
I'm crazy for this show it's just so
powerful I knew she was loved
you did everything you could for your
daughter
you can't say the same about you
if you had paid attention to Drea
instead of Blondie last year maybe we
wouldn't be it
and what did you do for Drea
yeah it's easy to talk but not so easy
to act now is it
we all got a story about how we could
have done more but failure to act
that's still failure
you are so powerful in this show is it
true that this show felt different for
you and
compelled I'm not a good crier at all
that's just I'm not my I'm not generally
that close to my emotions my negative
emotions if you will this show Not only
was I crying all day on set I would go
home and cry and I'm again like my
husband was kind of shocked because he's
never seen me that like crumbling like
that every every night for five months
um but it wasn't hard to cry I mean
partly because I you know as a at 19 I
was raped at gunpoint at my after-school
job
um
and even though I was raped at gunpoint
by a stranger at work I was still asked
what I had on
and
when you realize that folks will make
you complicit in your own abuse and
Trauma no matter the circumstances and
that will people will legitimately care
less about your life if
um you have too much melanin
that's that makes it easy to cry you
know
um and when I think about I was raped
one time 30 years ago
and I am still in therapy
but been once a week for 30 years I
still crumble I still am like PTSD is so
it's so it's right here it's right at my
fingertips
so no it's not hard to cry but when I
think about it happened one time
and what these folks are experiencing
with human trafficking sexual
trafficking
my my trauma my horror the worst
experience of my life is happening
multiple times a day
every day
indefinitely until they decide you have
no more value and and part of the
challenge is like what can we do we can
make sure we have enough tears for all
of our girls all of our boys
that we raise our voices in our
communities
when anyone goes missing
so
we we have the same resources the same
response the same care that can say the
same concern we can stop demonizing
black and brown girls black and brown
children
we can we can be really cognizant about
how we use words
so when you see a headline like juvenile
prostitutes you can call into your
newspaper or or media outlets and say
juveniles mean children and children
cannot consent to sex work children are
victims yes
we can demand better
you know
bringing it a little closer to home here
in New York last month a 12 year old
autistic girl
was lured away through Instagram
by a man her mother figured that out
and she was recovered in the Bronx
12 years old
through Instagram
how often are we policing our children's
social media
do we even know where to look do we even
know all of the new you know ways of of
communicating I know I don't but it's a
constant it's another job and that's the
point of the scene in that show that in
the show and the episode is so powerful
because a parent says my kid wouldn't do
that and you show them then snap of them
our kids too I mean the fact that I've
always loved you for your honesty and
your candor and your strength but today
and watching the show truth be told I
want to thank you with every fiber of my
being and my entire heart and Humanity
for shining a light on these important
subjects and facing these things and
giving recommendations and guidance and
understanding and as you said a voice to
this thank you thank you so much
once again
[Applause]
well I think it needs no further
explanation everybody check out the
extraordinary show on Apple TV plus
truth be told in its third season with
the incredible Gabrielle Union and the
wonderful Octavia Spencer
we'll be right back
[Music]